there are still a few resilient souls
playing on the dusty back streets of
delhi
but now even the national obsession has
finally
been run out
as the death toll sword and oxygen ran
short organizers insisted this
was an antidote to tragedy even a
display of humanity
as a humanitarian crisis raged outside
the stadium walls
but covered cases inside these
supposedly secured bubbles for players
and staff
forced an indefinite suspension of the
indian premier league
inevitable but some say too late it's
been a disaster on
all accounts humanitarian you know sort
of lack of conscience
lack of empathy and
also very scary for the rest of the
country that is stopped
at least in this so-called biosecure
bubble
where everything where even a ball that
goes to your stand is being cleaned and
wiped and stuck
and if the virus can reach that uh
what's the hope for the rest of us
stop needing a lot of help it was short
for many viewers the ipl
provided diversion even if there were
regular reminders of reality
their support and the safety of their
own home
nick knight was out in india
commentating having been out there
is just to perhaps try and give some
understanding as to what the ipl means
to a country that is completely obsessed
by
by the game for them to be able to
switch on
the television at seven o'clock at night
and to find
albeit in a small way a little bit of
solace a little bit of distraction
the 11 england players stranded in india
including sam curran and johnny barstow
now face an uncertain journey home there
may be uncomfortable questions too
about the india england test series in
february and march
60 000 packed this stadium in our
medabag
a city which soon became a coveted hot
spot
as the foreign players depart their
thoughts will likely be with the indian
people
this pandemic has reinforced that while
sport has an extraordinary ability to
lift the spirits
it's not a matter of life and death
martha kellner sky news